كان تصريح فلاديمير بوتين في سبتمبر
بمثابة تهديد ضئيل باستخدام
الأسلحة النووية ،
فقد تم تصعيده بهذه اللغة
لأنه يخسر الحرب في أوروبا
مطالبًا بأنه قد
يستخدم الأسلحة النووية من أجل تحقيق
أهدافه ،
شكرًا لك
منذ نهاية الحرب العالمية الثانية.
لقد جاءت الدول للحصول على
أسلحة نووية وتمتلكها حاليًا الصين
وفرنسا وروسيا والمملكة المتحدة
والولايات المتحدة التي تعد أيضًا
الأعضاء الخمسة الدائمين في
مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة ، ثم الهند
وباكستان ، ويعتقد أيضًا أن كوريا الشمالية وإسرائيل
تمتلكان أسلحة نووية روسيا
و  تمتلك الولايات المتحدة حتى الآن
أكبر ترسانة نووية تمتلك روسيا ما
يقرب من 6000 رأس حربي نووي
والولايات المتحدة لديها ما يقرب من 5400.
وغالبًا ما يشار إلى الأسلحة النووية التكتيكية
على أنها أسلحة Battlefield التي
يمكن استخدامها ضد العدو
العسكري ضد المنشآت أو
ضد المنشآت التكتيكية
يتم تعريف الأسلحة النووية أيضًا من خلال وجود
نواتج أقل  ومن المتوقع أن يكون لديهم
نطاقات أقصر من
الأسلحة النووية الاستراتيجية ، على النقيض من ذلك ،
فهي أكبر بكثير من حيث الحجم ، فهذه هي
أنواع الأسلحة التي تم استخدامها في
هيروشيما وناغازاكي
ويمكنها تسوية مدينة بأكملها
بحيث يمكن أن يتراوح إنتاج الأسلحة النووية
من 20 طنًا  على طول الطريق حتى 50
ميغا طن ،
يمكن لفلاديمير بوتين أن يلجأ إلى
الأسلحة النووية المستخدمة في ساحة المعركة
بسلاح نووي تكتيكي إذا كان
يدرك أنه يخسر الحرب ، فقد يكون ذلك
لتدمير عدو.ستهدف
قوات العدو ولكن هناك أيضًا
أسباب رمزية لذلك  يمكن لبوتين أن يستخدم سلاحًا نوويًا
يمكنه أن يشاهد مظاهرة تم
تصويرها في مكان ما مثل فوق البحر الأسود ،
وستكون هذه أيضًا محاولة لردع
الناتو في الغرب عن التدخل
بشكل أكثر مباشرة أو تقديم المزيد من الدعم
لمحاولات أوكرانيا لهزيمة روسيا
من احتمالية وجود سلاح نووي.  يظل استخدام الأسلحة
في أوكرانيا منخفضًا للغاية ، ومن
أفضل الطرق التي يمكن للولايات المتحدة
وحلف الناتو أن تردع بها روسيا تتمثل في إقناع
بوتين بأنه لن يفعل ذلك.  تحقيق أهدافه الاستراتيجية من
خلال استخدام الأسلحة النووية من
خلال توضيح له أن
أي أسلحة نووية تستخدم سيكون لها
عواقب وخيمة ،
ومع ذلك يجب أن تؤخذ تهديداته على
محمل الجد.